and i want to encourage you also to lean
into the preparation season of course we
want to get to 100 000 subscribers as
quick as possible but maybe there's
something that you need to learn out of
this present season maybe even this
season in obscurity is preparing you for
taking the leap into full-time youtube
doesn't normally happen overnight
usually there is personal development
business development and overall hustle
to get your dreams off the ground and at
coasting elevation i cannot wait to get
into today's episode
my name is heather torres and i'm the
host of the think media podcast the
number one podcast to help you grow your
influence on youtube and then turn that
influence into a high impact and a high
profit youtube channel and first before
we even get into the episode i am so
honored and excited to share with you
our holiday sale we have a special
promotion going on for you right now
where we have a brand new course
teaching you how to get to your first
1000 subscribers and earn 1 000 on
youtube without a fancy camera editing
experience or having to work 50 hours a
week on your youtube channel you can get
all the details at think holiday sale
well over the next few weeks during our
regular podcast upload our tuesday
ritual we are going to be walking
through a series called taking the leap
to full time now you might have noticed
that we are also uploading bonus
episodes here on the podcast so make
sure you're subscribed if you want to
get all of the content happening but
this series is going to walk through
taking the leap to full time and in
today's episode we're talking about the
law of preparation what does it take
what is the pre-work done before you
actually step out and start your channel
we're gonna be talking about all that
and more over this series so let's dive
into today's featured content
[Music]
real talk about quitting your job and
going full time on
youtube let me know do you uh want to go
full time on youtube is that one of your
ambitions i think by this time that's
why you're here but recommitting to
saying okay i'm trying to figure out the
path financially numerically my niche
all of those details and i want to tell
you a little bit of my story
in terms of
uh my journey to full-time and i have
never shared it at this level of detail
before so i'm super excited but i want
you to see this shot this is a
screenshot
of think media
over the last 10 plus years
pretty crazy i mean
10 million watch time minutes 1.8
million subscribers on the way to a
million dollars in just youtube ad
revenue generated but i want you to
really get some perspective on this
graph what we're looking at right here
my friends that's 2010.
can you see the clarity of this right
do you see how how flat that is right do
you see that there in fact there's a
little blip it's kind of hard to see on
the screen but if you zoom in or you're
watching on desktop you can see this
little blip right here right around 2012
like oh that was like a good month and
then we're back to flatline you know
what i'm saying and so there's 2010
right there is
2015.
okay
and today is 2021.
and so the journey has been crazy but
one thing i think that's pretty obvious
is you can see that these second
five years have been a lot crazier than
those first five years but this is why i
want to remind you to be patient and to
remember to be anchored in commitment
right great things take time and a lot
of people
overestimate what they can accomplish in
one year but they underestimate what
they can accomplish in 10 years
and so i want to remind you patience and
commitment but during that journey at
that middle of the graph right there in
2015 i want to tell you a story about
what happened right there at that
inflection point during that time my
family lost 90 percent of our income in
october of 2015. i'll never forget this
month you see throughout that year by
this point i had transitioned to
complete freelance work and i was doing
video production managing youtube
channels doing social media management
for three clients and i had i was living
in las vegas with my wife and our two
dogs rosie and sophie chihuahuas
and in october of 2015 i'm hustling as
hard as i can on youtube but i have a
lot of work with my freelance clients
and in the first month uh first week of
the month i got a phone call hey sean
yeah we gotta let you go now these
clients were paying me two thousand
dollars two thousand dollars and one
thousand dollars okay so i'm earning
five thousand dollars a month sixty
thousand dollars a year
working for freelance clients and i'm
trying to hustle on my own personal
channels right at the same time first
client calls me sean we gotta let you go
kind of bummed but i'm like it's only
one out of three what do you do if you
need clients you try to refill that slot
so a little distraught but
we're going to keep going second week of
october 2015. i get a phone call bring
sean
yeah
uh hey you know we hired some staff
we're rearranging some things we no
longer need your services as a
contractor we gotta let you go now oh
how the mighty fall because i lost two
two thousand clients
two thousand dollar clients in two weeks
so now i'm down to just that last client
and the honest truth is i'd already felt
like they were transitioning scaling
back on some things i'm like you know
figures you know what i mean if you ever
had one of those you're like might as
well also rain i might as well get a
flat tire and get in a fight with my i
mean like it's just one of those days oh
yeah and then you know and it was like
one of those months because sure enough
god is my witness third week i get a
phone call hey sean we got to let you go
so now
our income has been eviscerated and
about 80 to 90 of our income now we're
doing all right on youtube but it's
super early days you saw the graph it
was like it was pretty flat think media
is like 16 000 subscribers at the time
good but not like
not really dialed in and earning about
around a thousand dollars a month but
now that all the other income's gone
that a thousand dollars a month is not
enough to pay rent it's not enough to
cover the car bill it's not enough to
pay you know for just the insurance and
just all the expenses that come with
life
and so admittedly i started to panic a
little bit i'm i'm worried i'm like whoa
this came quick like i'm super nervous
and and i called a friend david
goldstein now this is david and you
could see him smiling he just never not
smiling because uh he's independently
wealthy not that that's the thing but
like i mean it's actually true we're
standing in front of his tesla right
back when tesla was like first dropped
because he was on like the waiting list
he got this tesla and he's like sean do
you want to come test the autopilot mode
i turned it into a video with him that's
david goldstein he's like sold multiple
companies so him and his wife alice are
just on vacation all the time and but
he's an incredible business mentor and
so i call him i'm like david dude my
clients are firing me i'm super worried
we've lost money we actually have about
maybe six months worth of reserves
based on income and everything else
before we hit zero in the bank i'm like
david
i'm super worried
and he goes
well uh he goes sean
i'm not worried
and i think to myself
it's the most defensive thing that i've
ever heard him once i know david i know
you're not worth you just paid cash for
a tesla
you've been on vacation and i don't you
don't sound worried sipping a pina
colada in in mexico on the beach with
alice like that's true story
and he's like i'm like i know you're not
worried i'm not sure if you heard me
david
i'm worried right like you don't
actually pay my bills bro and so i'm
actually kind of nerd but he goes no
listen and i'm glad he said it
ultimately because he was like no i'm
not worried because listen as an
entrepreneur at some point you have to
jump off the cliff
and sean it seems like god just kicked
you off the cliff
and it's your time to fly
you know what i mean like like riddle
masters that speak like that it's like a
wu-tang proverb just like it's you know
when us a boy's time to jump the cliff
you know what i mean and i was like all
right david like i know you're speaking
truth i feel that and and he was just
speaking from a different perspective to
say man it's time to go all in do i do i
try to hire more freelance clients in
this case i don't i go all in on youtube
so so here's i want to extrapolate some
of the principles that help me navigate
to full-time you got to discern for
yourself the season you're in but this
is just some moments and details from my
story so here's what happened this is
october the first three weeks i lose the
freelance clients
fourth week
i just watch netflix and like eat ben
and jerry's you know you're trying to
recover a little bit like but eventually
i'm like okay talk to david all right
it's time to lock and load patience and
commitment focus and discipline let's
freaking go
and so between november and december
2015 for two months
i posted
52 youtube videos this is just the exact
math i'm going to show you exactly what
i did
and at the time i was a solo youtube
creator i mean um you'll see i was kind
of collaborating with others you know my
friend benji who uh we did video
influencers together we were shooting
some stuff but i was the editor and the
thumbnail creator and i ran the blog
and i downloaded all the music and i
uploaded all the videos and i did all
the vra and all the titles and all the
video optimization and all the
descriptions and i did that for think
media and i did it i i you're gonna
notice i was actually spread acro across
three channels which i don't think is a
good idea but this is just my story and
and even better is to concentrate all
your energy on one channel but but for
two months now mind you no clients and
no job pure survival
i go all freaking in 52 original videos
so here's here's a screenshot of the
exact 52 videos
that i posted
on my channel think media
those are the exact topics you can see
five years ago i start off best travel
tripod bag by the way people think like
things are crowded dude nobody's doing
niche videos like that that's what we've
been talking about like all day you got
to find topics that twenty one thousand
views that could potentially be
profitable you know in terms of
affiliate marketing answer a very
specific question when we say specific
that's what we mean
specific right like that the best
travel
tripod bag 21 000 views over the last
five years but those are the videos on
that channel then we also had this video
influencers channel which at the time
was nice because we would go to one
event and interview
like a bunch of people all at once but
then i would go back to my house in
vegas and i would just edit edit edit
edit edit and put all and put all the
videos out and create the thumbnails and
yes
i'm doing photoshop that's what i use
and i do have a background of graphic
design so i'm coming into this season
with a skill set of building up and
learning skills remember i ask you
what's your pdp what's your personal
development plan like what skills are
you learning i'm coming into this season
with skills
so i there's the videos on on video
influencers and then here's some videos
on my personal channel sean cannell that
i posted as well those are the 52 videos
so i've got five lessons that i learned
from this season
and that i think you can apply
to get to full time faster and even
beyond to scale faster as well and the
first lesson is the law of preparation
the law of preparation malcolm x said
the future belongs to those who prepare
for it today
and brian tracy put it this way he said
effective performance is preceded
by painstaking preparation now if you
can relate the reason i love this quote
is because of the word painstaking
that's what a lot of people don't want
to actually invest in like they're like
okay i want to prepare i might want to
practice a little bit oh wait i'm going
to get my shoes dirty i don't know if it
gets hard no i'm talking that sometimes
preparation is painstaking like you need
to get uncomfortable like oh like the
software this video editing software's
so hard to learn have you even tried yet
yeah i sat there for like 20 minutes i
looked at it was confusing well
obviously like you sometimes got to
actually do things that get you
uncomfortable because on the other side
of that
painstaking preparation is a skill you
develop and eventually you're like ah
this is so easy i like but it does it's
not necessarily easy on the journey can
you relate
to some pain
in the process come on tell me in the
comments and so ultimately the law of
preparation was i had built up key word
here there was this moment where i lose
all my freelance clients
but i had built up the skills the
confidence and the knowledge for that
moment
you know in the 100 absolutely
unbreakable laws of success by brian
tracy he says the mark of a serious
person a real professional
in any field
is that he takes more time to prepare
than the average person do you hear that
those that are professionals youtube
entrepreneurs they take more time to
prepare than the non-serious person the
non-serious person always attempts to
bluff or wing it
kind of reminds me of the dabbler right
if you just been dabbling it's like i'm
just kind of trying to wing it i mean
i'm kind of throwing out some thumbnails
i'm trying to it's like no i'm going to
get serious about these details
right
and this is why abraham lincoln said
that uh uh he said as a young man in
springfield illinois i shall study and
prepare myself
and someday my chance will come
so i'm he just was like i'm gonna study
i'm going to prepare i'm going to do my
best right where i'm at right now and
someday my chance will come see that
someday became my one day when it was
actually a blessing that i lost all my
clients and i had someone speak into my
life that said it's time to jump man
it's time to take the leap and go all
in
and so
when i think about this preparation
season it was this whole season
if you look up on the screen now
that that looks flat
but it's not flat because you know when
a tree
how tall a tree is going to grow it
doesn't grow up first the roots grow
down first oh it's a little bit
invisible for those first five years and
then you look at the last five years and
you might have only looked at the last
five months at think media like oh i
found you guys like i'm seeing you on so
you know like i signed up for girl video
live that's pretty cool what you guys
got going man this must have just sprung
up out of nowhere like what a fast just
like you guys are like overnight success
overnight success
bruh overnight success takes 10 years
and there's that preparation season
where you're learning the lessons where
you're learning the details right
and i was learning from my full-time job
as a director of communications at a
church learning team teamwork i'm
learning social media i'm doing this
kind of stuff for clients i was studying
this whole time world-class
communicators ted talks books i was
creating videos when i could i was
taking online courses and attending
educational events like grow a video
live the key here was deliberate
practice and the key here was deliberate
experience please write that down see i
was deliberately practicing certain
things based on the books i was reading
the podcast i was listening to the
online courses i was buying the attend
the events i was attending but i was
also placing myself in situations i part
of the reason
i
took the job i was
in as a director of communications was i
always wanted to plant myself in seasons
that would develop me
i always wanted to be immersed in
seasons and situations that i could get
skills for my vision for the future
and so i'm grateful you know i look back
and i think man maybe i could have gone
all in i actually could have gone all in
on think media in 2010 and not flown to
vegas and not took this job at a church
uh called the church lv at the time and
been a director of communications but i
still needed some skills and some
development who even knows what would
have been different but i'm so grateful
for the law of preparation
what skills do you need to develop what
character maybe needs to develop in your
life now so that because you don't want
to get to a place of success you don't
want your your your chemistry or your
gifting or your charisma to take you
further than your character can keep you
man we see it all the time we see
celebrities we see actors we see
influencers crash and burn because
sometimes youtube growth and youtube
influence and youtube impact put so much
pressure on you that your marriage
begins to crumble and you can't handle
the stress so we start giving in to
toxic habits behaviors addictions and
things like that i'm sorry to go so deep
on you but these are just some of the
lessons that i've been learning and
that's the power of the preparation
season i want to encourage you also to
lean into the preparation season of
course we want to get to 100 000
subscribers as quick as possible but
maybe there's something that you need to
learn out of this present season maybe
even this season in obscurity is
preparing you for popularity and it
actually kind of reminds me of the story
of david and goliath right you've
probably heard the story before and it's
the story of this this absolutely
impossible
situation where there's a giant so much
bigger a man of war since birth someone
that there's no reason that
that david could ever take down goliath
but i want to share this story because
this is how you also might feel on
youtube
starting in 2021
looking at the competition
looking at yourself and being like
my channel's small
my business is small i feel like my
skills are small
i just feel like i mean who am i to go
up against
against the giants out there
like who even am i
like they got
swords and spears and stuff i got like a
few small stones and i got a sling like
who am i to go do this thing
like that giants just look so big
ahead of me
but i want to encourage you
there's something about the law of
preparation because when you look into
the recorded text of that story of david
versus goliath
the saul who was the king at the time
was talking to david he was like yo bro
listen there's no way you can go up
against this guy and possibly win that's
what he says he goes you can't fight
this guy and win you're only a boy and
he's been a man of war since his youth
there's no way you could go up against
your competitors on youtube and win
there's no way you could start in 2021
or 2023 or 2025 and win
the giant's too big
but check out what david said and i love
this he goes
i have been taken
care of my father's sheep and goats
and when a lion or a bear came to steal
the land from the flock i went after it
with the club and i rescued the lamb
from its mouth and if the animal turned
on me i'd catch it by the jaw and club
it to death i don't know if you've ever
read the bible man it gets real this is
like some gnarly gangster street stuff
here it's like i'm clubbing lions and
he's like and i've done this to both
lion and bears i'm gonna do it again to
this giant
so what does that illustrate it was that
if you're gonna be ready to take down
the giants in your future you can't
ignore the preparation in your present
there was sheep to protect there was
lions to fight there was bears to fight
and i'll tell you that sounds pretty
scary as well i mean really scary i
don't know david was like a real g man
he's grabbing lions and clubbing them
and stuff but i mean you got to fight
those smaller battles those smaller
challenges it starts with just mastering
canva and getting great at thumbnails it
starts with just tweaking in some of
your skills so that when the day comes
where a giant is standing before you
you're like listen dude
i'm so good with this these stones and
this sling i'm ready to take that thing
down
the law of preparation
the law of preparation so here's my
question for you
how deliberate are you being
about your practice and your preparation
deliberate
could you be more
intentional
about not just you know we're kind of
all practicing but by the way that word
deliberate
comes out of a study from malcolm
gladwell on those that get 10 000 hours
before they reach like mastery in their
field but here's what they discovered in
that study
they discovered that it wasn't just 10
000 hours of activity
it was 10 000 hours of deliberate
practice come on like i'm talking 10 000
hours of being like no i know what i'm
going for i know the specific skills i
want to sharpen
and so that is what i am headed towards
so how deliberate are you being about
your practice and your preparation
the law of preparation how deliberate
are you being in practice to prepare you
for going full time on youtube it was
interesting to watch back that clip
after our event growth video live kind
of remembering some of the moments in my
story but i'm curious heather you know
over the last five years you've been
practicing and developing here at think
media and a whole new set of skills and
there was five years before that a plus
where you're learning entrepreneurship
business marketing social media so what
are some of the things that you think
about that you did to deliberately
practice to become the leader and the
creator and the influencer that you are
today yeah a couple things come right to
mind um taking my journey back to
prior to me working at think media um i
was coaching um pre and post natal
fitness so i was working with groups of
women and i was learning so many skills
when it comes to what we're doing today
which is how do you structure um
how do you structure in motivation how
do you instructure and encouragement how
do you um how do you move people from
one thing to the next thing how do you
see results how do you get actual
results for people um so when i think
about
for me that was a big part of what i was
doing when i go back to even social
media understanding the dynamics of
online you know what does that even look
like i go back to you know just creating
accounts for small businesses and
testing out different types of copy
testing out different images what's
working what's not working i was so
dialed into trying to understand
analytics which is really boring really
like you're just looking at numbers all
the time i was so dialed into trying to
figure that out because i wanted to see
what made people tick and i think about
my whole journey as an entrepreneur it
really was that i wanted to consistently
study what made people actually take
action like what was the action of of
all of their things and when i think
back it was it was you know helping in
pre and post-natal fitness it was
working for small businesses it was
working at washington state parks and it
was just understanding
understanding dynamics of what makes
people move yeah and i think this is can
be encouraging because it shows us that
the journey to full time is not
overnight and that sometimes we're
comparing ourselves to others we don't
know what their preparation season has
been i mean i look back and again
there's so many things youtube is not
just learning cameras you got to learn
that it's not just learning editing or
learning how to make thumbnails or even
learning optimization or titles and all
that different stuff but my season in
not just being in church i was a part of
a bible school where i was teaching and
in classes learning how to teach how to
structure teaching which is something
that a lot of us do on youtube we
actually teach and the quality of that
is going to be determined by how good of
a teacher you are by how you might
structure things with story or the your
opening argument or all these different
details these are some of the things
that you know i think think media
podcast listeners could think about now
what have you learned in terms of debate
class it's going to help you maybe make
a persuasive argument and so um you know
as we maybe put some handles on here and
i wanna hear some more um insights from
you i think there's three big things
that i wanna unpack in terms of the law
of preparation on the journey to full
time the first is is a pdp a personal
development plan this idea of deliberate
practice and deliberate experience and
then finally the proximity principle and
so if we were to put handles on this and
even some maybe takeaways and tips i
think that first of all you do need a
pdp now it might not be super official
maybe people don't think about that term
but people like those who really go full
time those who are become great at their
craft and build a career they do have a
personal
development plan for you
how what were some of the things you did
intentionally to just grow pre really
focusing on youtube and even during this
youtube season yeah i actually take it
all the way back to um when i had my
first baby after i had my first baby um
i experienced without knowing that i had
postpartum depression and when you're in
that season and it feels really foggy
your days just kind of drift you don't
really know i mean you know you're in a
day obviously but it just you just feel
like you're under this cloud and i just
remember thinking i've got to figure out
how to get out of this and i was
fortunate enough to seek help and one of
the things that my counselor said was
what are you doing to just get outside
what are you doing as a daily routine to
just get yourself outside so when i
think all the way back not what i'm
doing today but where i really started
to understand personal development was
in this idea of what is my daily routine
and what does winning look like and when
i think back it was things like did i
make my bed today personal development
is are you do you have tidiness around
you right are you are you accomplishing
something and at that point with
postpartum depression it was are you
making your bed um am i working out
every day and that doesn't mean i'm like
lifting weights and like you know going
hardcore did i go for a walk did i do
you know what was i doing and then it
started to develop into what am i
actually listening to what am i putting
into myself am i watching way too much
oprah yes i was right way too much oprah
way too much hgtv or tlc at that time
way too much like i didn't know i was
pregnant type stuff you're like the
crazy things because i was just sitting
as like kind of in this moment and i
thought no no i i'm turning off the tv
what can i put into my mind that could
actually be beneficial and that's
actually when i discovered tony robbins
and whether you agree or don't agree
with tony robbins
that doesn't bother me at all but for me
i was just
then invited into this whole new space
of what to think so my personal
development plan starting way back in
this journey was really about my health
of my mind body and soul and so i really
started to dive into what was that now
it's fully developed into a morning
routine i i'm so structured on you know
how can we help develop other people and
and just so much more but really it
starts and my and when i start to fall
off of it it always go back goes back to
those things my health my body mind and
soul
and that's similar to me as well i'm a
huge believer in um you are what you eat
if you want to become a full-time
youtuber are you eating the diet that is
going to develop you into that character
are you learning those skills and i
think part of a personal development
plan i think a lot of people can get
stuck have you noticed this in okay well
growth for me is watching then endless
youtube videos endless online courses
endless books endless uh podcasts and
that can lead to information
overload and it can lead to overwhelm we
also need that experience have you
noticed this absolutely and for me it
really
when i think back to you know um i've
never been really comfortable in front
of the camera i am now because i've
developed that skill but man when i go
back to it i was like well how can i
just make fun videos for my church or
how can i like get around what i want to
be doing how can i be around people who
are growing businesses and what does
that look like and and so much of it was
just sitting behind and not actually
doing and people need to do they need to
actually step up and not just consume
but create and actually you know really
dive into where where do they want to go
and where where are they stepping
outside their comfort zone to make those
things happen how about you yeah well i
mentioned in that talk the ten thousand
hour roll too and i think when malcolm
gladwell in the book outliers was
unpacking that study it was that those
who had mastery in their craft had 10
000 hours of
deliberate practice they didn't have 10
000 hours of listening to a podcast now
we hope that you keep listening to the
think media podcast because of course
education information that's an aspect
of
sharpening the saw but deliberate
practice is the real needle mover yeah
and i have a great example my husband
isaiah you know he's approaching 44 and
because we've been able to um to grow
this business he has the opportunity now
to really chase his dreams you know he
really supported our family um early on
working two jobs three jobs you know
developing out a career and now because
we're in this situation where we're both
able to really focus on what we want to
do
he now has decided to become a pro
golfer now he's doing great he's a
semi-pro golfer right now doing
different things but the shift happened
for him in the same way you're saying
about those 10 000 hours from
watching golf every weekend and like
sometimes practicing like going out with
the guys to now no he's invested into
this he is he is you know he's a
membership at a place and not just to go
on saturdays and drink beers but he's
going almost every day to be practicing
his different putts he's going uh he's
studying um what does this iron do
versus that iron how about you know when
the wind is like this what does that do
to the ball and you know really
understanding that it's not just about
the consumption of the thing you want to
do but it's about doing the things that
you actually want to do and it goes back
to any i mean you look at the any of the
greats kobe bryant i'm just naming
sports people now which is probably the
only sports person i know uh but they
were always doing things behind the
scenes that you never saw which is what
actually affected the games that they
played yeah i mean i think that that is
maybe a call out to some a lot of people
listening to this and a lot of aspiring
full-time youtubers are you
practicing ten thousand hours or are you
just watching other creators watching
your favorite teachers on youtube
constantly consuming content it's not 10
000 hours of watching youtube it's 10
000 hours of deliberate practice and
that is also deliberate experience and
one of my favorite concepts i i learned
a term for it later and it sort of spoke
to what i referenced the 2010 to the
2015
era in my life of the proximity
principle now our friend ken coleman at
ramsey solutions really helps people
with their careers and he talks about uh
he has a book called the proximity
principle and it's simply this that if
you want to do something in your future
the question is what do you want to do
in your future if you're listening to
this series on the think media podcast
you want to be full-time on youtube you
want to be a youtube entrepreneur okay
if you want to do that
can you today before the views are there
before the subscribers are there and you
need to have some type of a job could
you find a job or an internship or a
place where you work part-time that
actually
will get you closer to your goal can you
get in proximity with somebody who's
already doing what you want to do
and sometimes people think well i don't
know i i don't know any full-time
youtubers that i could go work for well
i didn't work for a full-time youtuber i
worked at a church
because what i had identified was i
identified the skill sets i identified
that okay what are some of the things i
need to learn i need to learn
communication i need to learn um
teamwork and leadership i need to learn
communication for a team not just
communication on camera or on our online
stream or to people in seats i want to
understand human psychology i want to
understand people i want to understand
and so uh i immersed myself and i i
believe there's one part of things where
you know we make our plans god directs
our steps and i can see that through
line in my entire life but i was also
making a practical decision when i got
the opportunity to move to las vegas and
work under benny perez who's a
phenomenal global communicator who had
built this incredible church that also
um was this huge opportunity that also
scared me stretched me way out of my
comfort zone it was way beyond where i
was at that environment leveled me up
and
that tipping point that one day when i
had to go full time was a lot prepper
that was my season of lions tigers and
bears
and and constantly be putting sometimes
i'd be challenged to do things like hey
do you want to speak on sunday one time
i got to speak on sunday these the 1500
people i think would be sitting in a
service that's kind of scary i'd be like
wow i'd spoke to 50.
now that's kind of writing on this
multi-generations people of all ages
there's every ever generations in the
room now i'm really in pressure
situations that are developing me and
that's the proximity principle who can
you get around who can you intern for
what volunteer work can you do or what
career can you take or what side work
can you take even those freelance
clients that i took
i was so excited to work for them
because i was cutting up their longer
form communication into micro social
media clips because i knew i wanted to
do that in the future i knew i wanted to
write books in the future and i was
helping benny perez write books and and
working with getting the covers designed
proximity principle in your preparation
season man it's so important and i
always wonder and i think we could ask
the think media podcast this
you know we reference the story of david
and goliath like what would have
happened if david had ran away from the
lion and the bear during those seasons
what would have happened like and
honestly i'm not
i
would have
if a bear if i got 100 sheep
and a bear comes up and grabs one of the
sheep i'm just doing the math i'm like i
still got 99 dude like i don't know like
i i mean because and a man and these 99
sheep like
to be honest if their shepherd gets
taken out man there could be more i'm
now i'm like justifying in my mind i'm
like reasoning i'm like you know what
bear's hungry this is this is kind of
the law of nature like there's a lot of
ways i could reason that away but what
that tells us is david wasn't shrinking
back from the smaller battles today that
had he not fought and won those he
wouldn't have been ready for the bigger
battle tomorrow
man that that that pressure season that
painstaking preparation and not just
deliberate practice or pod deliberate
podcasts
but deliberate experience what do you
think about that yeah you're so hitting
it and you know i think one of the
things too
is um is the give
without the ask and when you're getting
in these situations when you're trying
to get in proximity i remember um
so many times where it's like someone's
working on this project and i'm like can
i just be a part of it like can i just
like be a fly on the wall i will hold i
will take out the trash i will you know
whatever that is and not feeling like
you need to be the main person i was
like i just want to be around this and
uh i was uh when i was in my early 20s i
was a part of a company and i was just
around these people who were building
these businesses and i'm like can i just
carry your bag like to the thing so that
we can just talk in the elevator and
thinking about that type of proximity
but even going deeper when you think
about are you actually putting yourself
in uncomfortable situations like are you
actually signing up for the things that
scare you a little bit are you going to
the conference where you're like i don't
know any of this but the people around
me will um that's so important and are
you involved in something that's bigger
than you are you involved in something
i'm sure sean when you were at the
church and you were like i want to
develop these skills you weren't
actually like thinking one day at think
media i'm gonna hire 18 people you were
like not at all you were like you know
what this is actually moving me outside
of my comfort zone and i'm gonna just
dig into it i'm gonna figure out what is
what can i learn from the situation so
that later in life i can apply it being
around people getting in proximity being
in the right rooms being near the people
who are doing the thing so important but
so many people go into those situations
saying what can i get out of this rather
than just saying what can i just give to
this situation whether it's a low skill
whatever it is
you'll talk later in this series about
how you and i met
there was no ask it was like hey i want
to get in proximity to someone who's
doing something kind of like me how can
we work together what can we do together
what skills can i bring to the table and
there was no ask on either one of our
parts it was very much just like hey
we both have a vision let's just kind of
get around people who are doing the
things that we want to do so what
meetups are you going to what groups are
you a part of where are you being
pressured pressure makes diamonds where
are you being refined
in your life right now
man i'm so pumped and those are great
insights this five part series is going
to be fun and we're on this mission to
help people get to full time and that
sometimes i think realistically we want
to help people get to full time faster
it really depends on where you're
starting yeah you know but maybe i'm
packing that there's these 2010 to 2015
season of think media and then there's
even the last 2015 to 2021 and beyond
these different seasons like great
things take time and so in this law of
preparation episode it's a five part
series and i think each of these points
that we're going to kind of build out
some nuances around are absolutely
critical kind of a recap for you think
media podcast what is your personal
development plan like what are you
intentionally learning what skills do
you need to develop next in terms of
your youtube career or maybe in its
might not just be youtube in terms of
maybe the business you're gonna build
about around youtube or who you need to
become character wise as a leader or
just even just basic discipline in life
what are you deliberately practicing and
is there something that you could have
deliberate experience in right now
sometimes
there was part of i was chipping away at
my youtube channel on the side heather
um and
but my main priority was the church i
knew what my priorities were right
because that was my career it was who
was paying me so i wasn't posting a
video a week i was posting a video every
week during summer and then a video when
i could during other seasons of my life
because i was really i knew the season i
was in and i wanted to make sure that i
didn't miss that i was planted deeply in
the season that i was in and that i
didn't miss on all of the potential
nutrients around me
from
interpersonal relationships teamwork
relationships opportunities and that
season really developed me again if
you're listening to this would you be
willing to be maybe a little bit more
patient with your timeline
i might not be full-time on youtube in
two years because for the next two years
i need some deliberate experience i want
to actually get that painstaking
preparation so i'm gonna take that job
or switch my career or go work at that
marketing firm or go join that person
or apply to think media or whatever and
say like i actually realize i need to be
immersed and i've actually learned i
really believe this that actually the
best way to get to your own vision is to
serve someone else's vision first for
each man we both lived that we both
lived it yeah and and and completely
thinking that sometimes
that ambition to rush towards our vision
it may not a work out or again we might
get there and we're not ready for it we
haven't developed the character for it
so what is your pdp what are you
deliberately prac practicing and and
then what what about the proximity
principle who could you get around who
could you reach out to i think people
are afraid just go for it yeah just try
they might say no there might be you
know you could try to do an internship
you could try to work at a different
company you could you might also have to
be willing to move yes we've both done
that we've both done that i i moved the
move to las vegas
triggered a series of events in my life
that are absolutely remarkable i could
have never predicted it yeah but i
realized that's true proximity principle
we're living in an era where you can do
things online you can be on teams on
zoom you can work remote but there's
something powerful about proximity that
i really believe can push a lot of us
towards full-time on youtube
well i hope that that content helped you
and your takeaway question today is
are you putting in the hours and the
practice needed to actually grow this
youtube channel are you around the
people that you want to be around in
order to grow this youtube channel we're
going to be diving into more of this
topic over the next few weeks so make
sure that you're subscribed here on the
podcast whether you're listening to it
on apple itunes or if you're over on
youtube watching this or listening while
you're doing the dishes make sure you're
subscribed wherever you're consuming
this content and today i would love to
shout out one of our trusted listeners
and it's brought to you by our think
holiday sale this is a brand new course
that we have for you so you can get all
of the details of how you can get your
first or next 1000 subscribers your
first 1000 or next dollars on youtube
and so much more so go to
thinkholidaysale.com for the latest
promotion and all of the details now i
want to shout out braxtor vision braxtor
says has it all fun and inspirational
content that speaks to mind body and
soul for both your business and your
personal lifestyle goals so yeah it
basically has it all thank you so much
baxter for that comment that is what our
heart and mission is here on the think
media podcast we want to bring you
conversations with different influencers
and go deeper into the conversations not
really talked about on the platform so
thank you so much for leaving that
comment over on apple itunes if you have
not yet rated and reviewed the podcast
you can do that now after you're done
listening to today's episode and i also
want to shout out burgeet beckley from
our youtube channel thank you so much
think media team and sean for having me
on today loved the conversation and gave
us a lot to chew on see you guys at
growth video live 2022 brandon and
brigitte well thank you so much for
leaving that comment i cannot wait to
hug you in person at
growwithvideolive2022. thank you so much
for listening to today's episode and
we'll catch you in the next one did you
see thinkmediasale.com
for the holidays we're giving you 80
off our brand new youtube made simple
course bundle get over one thousand nine
hundred dollars worth of our best
courses tools templates and more just go
to thinkmediasale.com
[Music]
you